diesen nobelpreis bekommen und ist auch
schon von repressalien erfasst worden
es geht um kontakte zu drogenkartellen
um steuerhinterziehung
das sind natürlich alles themen die die
ausländischen geheimdienste extrem
interessieren und der bnd sucht eben
auch mit select ohren diese daten ab die
ihm von ausländischen geheimdiensten
geliefert werden und er leitet
informationen auch in diese
geheimdienste weiter und zwar zum teil
sogar automatisiert und insofern
fürchten diese journalisten und
journalistinnen erstmal das vielleicht
eigene informationen bekannt werden die
dem eigentlichen redaktionsgeheimnis der
pressefreiheit natürlich unterfallen und
zum anderen fürchten sie um den schutz
ihrer quellen
die ganz sensible daten natürlich
preisgeben können sprechen wir gleich
noch mal weiter drüber wir geben jetzt
in den saal denn es geht gleich los mit
der verhandlung mit dem uhr mit der
urteilsverkündung
ja es entscheidet der erste senat des
verfassungsgerichts und das dürfte hier
eine premiere sein
auf augenhöhe mit den
verfahrensbeteiligten die richter kommen
von der richterbank herunter da im
vorderbereich mehr platz ist und die
krone abstandsregeln so eingehalten
werden können der zweite senat hatte vor
zwei wochen beim ezb überzahl noch einen
anderen weg gewählt der blieb oben
sitzen allerdings waren auch nur fünf
richter dann mit der urteilsverkündung
anwesend
ja und der vorsitz hatte stefan haben
beide präsident des
bundesverfassungsgerichts dieser wird
dann zunächst die verfahrensbeteiligten
aufrufen das wird wenige minuten dauern
dann verkündet er das urteil umfasst
danach die entscheidung zusammen dieser
zusammenfassung hören wir uns an und
sprechen dann die besprechen dann die
folgen der entscheidung
das bundesverfassungsgericht
bitte nehmen sie platz
guten morgen ich begrüße sie im namen
des gesamten senats im
bundesverfassungsgericht unter sichtbar
geänderten bedingungen aufgrund der
infektion schützen den maßnahmen gegen
die ausbreitung der pandemie die
verlagerung der richterbank war
notwendig um die hierfür erforderlichen
abstände einhalten zu können das gleiche
gilt für die beschränkung der anzahl der
sitzplätze
ich möchte sie schon jetzt bitten bei
gesprächen beim weiteren aufenthalt im
gebäude des bundesverfassungsgerichts
nach der verkündung zu ihrem
gesundheitsschutz
aber auch zu dem der anderen ebenfalls
auf die einhaltung des notwendigen
abstand zu achten
ich eröffne hiermit die sitzung des
ersten senats des
bundesverfassungsgerichts zur verkündung
des urteils in dem verfahren 1 bvr 2835
auf 17 über die verfassungsbeschwerde
der reporter softer der frau katia
ismailowa des herrn paul von bildung des
herrn richard gordon taylor das
handlager des herrn ross castillo ist
ein koran laptop und des herrn michael
gegen § 6 absätze 1 2 3 und 6 § 7 absatz
1 § 9 absätze 4 und 5 § 10 absatz 3 § 13
absatz 4 314 absatz 1 satz 1 oder absatz
2 § 15 absatz 1 § 19 absatz 1 § 24
absatz 1 satz 1 absätze 2 und 3 des
gesetzes über den
bundesnachrichtendienst in der fassung
des gesetzes zur ausland ausland
fernmelde aufklärung des
bundesnachrichtendienstes vom 23
dezember 2016
wir kommen zunächst zur feststellung der
anwesenheit ich bitte sich bei
namensaufruf jeweils kurz zu erheben
zur verkündung des urteils sind
erschienen
für die beschwerdeführer der
geschäftsführer der report erst aufgrund
ihrer christian
sowie als bevollmächtigter aller
beschwerdeführer herr professor doktor
matthias becker die beschwerdeführerin
reporters hausfront er wird zudem von
herrn rechtsanwalt dr wie chamonix
vertreten für die bundesregierung sind
erschienen aus dem bundeskanzleramt herr
staatssekretär johannes geis mann sowie
als bevollmächtigter herr professor
doktor joachim wieland als sachkundige
dritte sind erschienen für das
parlamentarische kontrollgremium der
vorsitzende das mitglied des bundestags
für armin schuster
der stellvertretende vorsitzende das
mitglied des bundestags herr dr
konstantin von notz sowie das mitglied
des parlamentarischen kontrollgremiums
das mitglied des bundestags herr stephan
thomae für die g 10-kommission der
stellvertretende vorsitzende herr doktor
berthold huber ist verhindert weiterhin
sind erschienen für das unabhängige
gremium nach § 16 bnd gesetz der
vorsitzende richter am bundesgerichtshof
josef hoch wir kommen nun zur
urteilsverkündung es wird folgendes
urteil verkündet
im namen des volkes aufgrund der
mündlichen verhandlung vom 14 und 15
januar 2020 hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht erster senat
für recht erkannt
erstens paragrafen 6 7 13 bis 15 des
gesetzes über den
bundesnachrichtendienst in der fassung
des gesetzes zur ausland ausland
fernmelde aufklärung des
bundesnachrichtendienstes kommt
dreiundzwanzigster dezember 2016
auch in der fassung des gesetzes zur
anpassung des datenschutzrechts an die
verordnung eu 2016 679 unser umsetzung
der richtlinien die eu 2016 680 vom 30
juni 2017 sind mit artikel 10 absatz 1
des grundgesetzes sowie mit artikel 5
absatz 1 satz 2 des grundgesetzes nicht
vereinbar
2 § 19 absatz 1 § 24 absatz 1 satz 1
absatz 2 satz 1 absatz 3 des gesetzes
über den bundesnachrichtendienst sind
mit artikel 10 absatz 1 des
grundgesetzes sowie mit artikel 5 absatz
1 satz 2 des grundgesetzes nicht
vereinbar so weit sie zur verarbeitung
von im zusammenhang mit der
strategischen fernmelder aufklärung nach
paragrafen 6 7 13 bis 15 des gesetzes
über den bundesnachrichtendienst
erhobenen personenbezogenen daten
ermächtigung drittens bis zu einer
neuregelung längstens jedoch bis zum 31
dezember 2021 gelten die für mit dem
grundgesetz unvereinbar erklärten
vorschriften haut viertens die
bundesrepublik deutschland hat in
beschwerdeführerinnen und
beschwerdeführern ihre notwendigen
auslagen
aus dem verfassungsbeschwerde verfahren
zu erstatten bitte nehmen sie wieder
platz
sehr geehrte damen und herren das
bundesverfassungsgericht hatte die frage
zu entscheiden ob die derzeitige
gesetzliche regelung der überwachung der
telekommunikation von ausländern im
ausland durch den
bundesnachrichtendienst mit dem
grundgesetz vereinbar ist
diese frage bewegt sich an der
schnittstelle mehrere unsere zeit
prägender entwicklungen der instituts
der internationalisierung im allgemeinen
der wachsenden internationalen
dimensionen sicherheitsbezogene
herausforderungen und reaktionen der
rasanz technologischer entwicklungen
insbesondere der digitalisierung und der
hiermit einhergehenden wachsenden und
auch neuartigen verwundbarkeit von
rechtsgütern das zugrundeliegende
verfahren erweist sich insoweit als
spiegel seiner zeit
das urteil lässt sich wie folgt
zusammenfassen
die derzeitige gesetzliche regelung ist
wegen verstoßes gegen das zitiergebot
formell verfassungswidrig und steht auch
inhaltlich nicht im einklang mit
zentralen verfassungsrechtlichen
anforderungen der gesetzgeber hat jedoch
die möglichkeit die gesetzlichen
grundlagen der ausland ausland
fernmelder aufklärung verfassungskonform
auszugestalten
im einzelnen artikel 10 und artikel 5
grundgesetz schützen seit jeher
unstrittig auch ausländer
die heutige entscheidung stellt klar
dass dies nicht nur im inland gilt
artikel 1 absatz 3 grundgesetz bindet
die deutsche staatsgewalt umfassend an
die grundrechte des grundgesetzes
folglich auch im ausland dies gilt
jedenfalls für die grundrechte als
abwehrrechte gegenüber maßnahmen der
überwachung wie sie hier in rede stehen
in einer solchen wirkung der grundrechte
auch im ausland liegt kein übergriff in
fremde rechtsordnungen weil es nur um
die frage der grundrechtlichen bindung
der deutschen staatsgewalt nicht um
diejenige einer ausländischen
staatsgewalt geht die bindung der
deutschen staatsgewalt an die
grundrechte auch im ausland verhindert
dass der grundriss
schutz in einer internationalisierten
welt hinter dem handlungsradius der
deutschen staatsgewalt zurück bleibt
oder sogar unterlaufen werden kann
der persönliche und sachliche
schutzbereich grund rechtlicher
verfügungen kann im inland einerseits
und dem ausland andererseits indes
differieren
ebenso ist bei der bestimmung der
verfassungsrechtlichen anforderungen an
die rechtfertigung von
grundrechtseingriffen den besonderheiten
der einbindung staatlichen handelns und
ein ausländisches umfeld rechnung zu
tragen
kompetenz rechtliche bedenken gegen die
angegriffenen regelungen bestehen nicht
die gesetzgebungskompetenz des bundes
für auswärtige angelegenheiten
gemäss artikel 73 absatz 1 nummer 1
grundgesetz ist eröffnet da das
zitiergebot artikel 19 absatz 1 satz 2
grundgesetz nicht beachtet wurde sind
die angegriffenen vorschriften indes
formell verfassungswidrig
auch in inhaltlicher hinsicht
entsprechend sie in ihrer derzeitigen
ausgestaltung zentralen
verfassungsrechtlichen anforderungen
nicht
trotz des besonders schweren eingriffs
gewichts das mit maßnahmen der
strategischen auslands
kommunikationsüberwachung verbunden ist
kann diese allerdings
verfassungsrechtlich gerechtfertigt sein
dies beruht entscheiden auf dem
überragenden öffentlichen interesse an
einer wirksamen auslandsaufklärung im
interesse der außen- und
sicherheitspolitische handlungsfähigkeit
der bundesrepublik deutschland sowie den
besonderen schwierigkeiten staatlichen
handelns im ausland dieser befund
berechtigt den gesetzgeber im grundsatz
zur anlasslosen strategischen
telekommunikationsüberwachung im ausland
unter verzicht auf objektivierte
eingriffsschwellen die ausgestaltung der
strategischen auslands überwachung ist
jedoch in verhältnismäßiger weise zu
begrenzen
dies betrifft im einzelnen das verbot
globaler und pauschaler überwachung die
aussonderung von daten aus inlands
kommunikation die präzise und
normenklare festlegung der
überwachungszwecke die strukturierung
der ausrichtung auf die festgelegten
überwachungszwecke spezifische
anforderungen an die bevorratung von
daten an die zielgerechte an die
zielgerichtete erfassung bestimmter
personen
an den schutz von vertraulichkeit
beziehungen und an den umgang mit dem
kernbereich privater lebensgestaltung
sowie die vorgabe von lösungs pflichten
die übermittlung von daten an andere
stellen ist nur unter beachtung der
grundsätze der sogenannten
hypothetischen daten neue erhebung
verhältnismäßig dies gilt allerdings
nicht für die übermittlung
personenbezogener daten an die
bundesregierung zum zwecke der
politischen information bei der
übermittlung an ausländische stellen
bedarf es zusätzlich der vergewisserung
über die einhaltung rechtsstaatlicher
standards auf empfängerseite spezifische
anforderungen ergeben sich im rahmen
verfassungsrechtlich grundsätzlich
gestattet kooperationen mit
ausländischen diensten insbesondere an
den einsatz fremd benannte suchbegriffe
und an die übermittlung sogenannter und
selektierte verkehrsdaten mit blick auf
den verfassungsrechtlich grundsätzlich
gestatteten ausschluss von
auskunftsansprüchen und
benachrichtigungs pflichten und die
damit verbundene zurücknahme der
praktischen möglichkeit individuellen
rechtsschutz zu erlangen sowie
angesichts der im wesentlichen allein
final strukturierten befugnisse bedarf
es zum ausgleich einer ausgebauten
unabhängigen objektiv rechtlichen
kontrolle
dabei ist einerseits eine gerichts
ähnliche andererseits eine
administrative kontrolle im
institutioneller eigenständigkeit
sicherzustellen die nicht durch die serc
partie wohl behindert werden da die
beanstandeten vorschriften gelten
vorläufig längstens bis zum 31 dezember
2021 fort danach lässt das grundgesetz
dem gesetzgeber substanziellen raum
aktuellen außen und
sicherheitspolitische herausforderungen
auch mit dem instrument der
strategischen auslands
kommunikationsüberwachung zu begegnen
zugleich setzt die verfassung ihm dafür
aber gehaltvolle grundrechtliche grenzen
und zwar auch im verhältnis zu
ausländern im ausland so weit kurz
skizziert die wesentlichen gründe die
den senat zu seiner entscheidung bewogen
haben nunmehr folgt die begründung im
einzelnen
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat also
entschieden die aktuelle auslands
auslands überwachung des
bundesnachrichtendienstes ist in
mehrfacher hinsicht verfassungswidrig
spätestens ab 2022 darf der bnd so nicht
weiter arbeiten ja wie gesagt das urteil
wird ja jetzt noch an einzelheiten
verkündet da sind dann wirklich die
detailregelungen drin
aber was wir jetzt schon sagen können
ist der eine paukenschlag grundrechte
gelten auch für ausländer im ausland das
hat das bundesverfassungsgericht hier
mit meisterhaften zum ersten mal
entschieden und daher darf der bnd
ebenso global um pauschalen seien
überwachungsmaßnahmen nicht weitermachen
auch muss die kontrolle offenbar
gestärkt werden
seehofer das sind doch schon die jetzt
hier anklingen lassen doch behindern
wohl doch die arbeit des bnd oder sie
werden die arbeit des bnd erstmal etwas
behindern
da muss hausinternen geprüft werden wie
können wir mit dieser entscheidung
umgehen
und da muss auch die bundesregierung
eine entscheidung treffen insbesondere
ist es ja erforderlich jetzt das bnd
gesetz zu navigieren
und da ist der zeitrahmen relativ eng
bis ende 21 von daher hat der
gesetzgeber seine hausaufgaben zu machen
aber es hatte sich ja schon in der
entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts aus dem jahre
1999 angedeutet dass hier möglicherweise
artikel 10 auch bei der auslands
auslandsaufklärung eingreifen könnte das
hatte der senat seinerzeit offen
gelassen und zwar deswegen weil es dort
um die überwachung der kommunikation
inland nach der inland ausland ging für
die die g 10 kommission zuständig ist
und von daher war es keine frage dass
artikel 10 berührt ist und
wir werden aller voraussicht nach in den
entscheidungsgründen auch die aussage
finden
das entscheidend ist dass der bnd ja die
auswertung der erkenntnisse die erfasst
werden durch eine deutsche behörde im
inland erfolgt und das von daher schon
die grundrechts bindung gegeben ist das
war ja auch schon die aussage 1999 ja
frau am markt etwas wie sehen sie die
entscheidung sind sehr erfreut als
mitglied der gesellschaft für
freiheitsfest ja absolut also das hätten
wir uns glaube ich kaum besser wünschen
können
das gericht hat hier anerkannt dass eben
die kommunikations grundrechte und auch
die pressefreiheit hier tatsächlich
betroffen sind welt hier tatsächlich
betroffen sind und dass der gesetzgeber
hier nachlegen muss und wir sind
natürlich jetzt sehr gespannt was genau
für vorgaben wir jetzt auch noch in den
gründen finden werden aber ich denke ein
ganz großer sieg liegt darin dass jetzt
hier tatsächlich die grundrechts bindung
deutscher behörden durchgehend
festgestellt worden ist das also
deutsche behörden sich dadurch nicht
ihren verfassungsrechtlichen bindungen
entledigen können dass sie einfach ins
ausland gehen und dort tätig werden
damit bringt das
bundesverfassungsgericht den deutschen
grundrechtsschutz auf eine linie mit
völkerrechtlichen vorgaben der
europäische gerichtshof für
menschenrechte hat ja schon in einer
ganzen serie von entscheidungen klar
gemacht es gibt keine ausübung von
hoheitsgewalt ohne dann in dem fall
menschen rechtliche bindungen und das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat jetzt eben
klar gestellt
natürlich gelten die sogenannten
jedermanns grundrechte wie eben die
kommunikations grundrechte und die
pressefreiheit hier in deutschland auch
für ausländer aber sie gelten eben auch
im ausland das grundgesetz kennt da
keine territoriale begrenzung ja anders
die auffassung des
bundesnachrichtendienstes wir haben mal
mit dem ehemaligen präsidenten herrn
schindler gesprochen was er davon hält
ausländer im ausland kontrasten
beizumessen grundrechte sind nicht dazu
da die gesamte weltbevölkerung unter
ihren schutz zu setzen
das wäre anmaßend und das wäre auch
eine bedenkliche verabsolutierung
deutscher rechtsposition ja das wäre
rechts imperialismus und ich glaube auch
die väter des grundgesetzes würden sich
im grabe umdrehen wenn sie wüssten dass
der taliban der gerade deutsche soldaten
in afghanistan angreift in seiner
kommunikation durch artikel 10 geschützt
werden soll oder wenn der arabische
terrorist der gerade eine geisel köpfe
in seiner kommunikation durch das
fernmeldegeheimnis des grundgesetzes
geschützt sein soll
formaxx was sagen sie dazu hat er recht
geht das nicht zu weit dass wir jetzt
wirklich quasi global alle den
grundrechtsschutz beimessen
also ich weiß nicht ob sich die grund
die väter und mütter des grundgesetzes
nicht eher wundern würden dass die
bundeswehr in afghanistan ist also das
war glaube ich 949 so noch nicht
vorgesehen
aber es geht vor allem darum dass es
gerade nicht ein übergriff ist auf
fremde rechtsordnung das hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht ja auch ganz
klar gesagt wir machen jetzt nicht
anderen regierungen vorschriften sondern
wir begrenzen unsere eigene regierung
und wenn dann liegt ein eingriff darin
dass der bundesnachrichtendienst
aufklärung im ausland durch vornimmt
dass er das aber nicht in großem umfang
der darf das ist ja eigentlich eine
verbesserung der situation für andere
staaten und das jetzt fremde stadt
bürger zusätzlich zu dem rechts regime
was ihr im inland haben auch noch
möglicherweise grundrecht in deutschland
haben das greift in keiner weise auf die
anderen staaten überall sie haben ja die
grundrechte nicht gegenüber den anderen
staaten sondern nur gegenüber der
bundesregierung und das starten kontexte
mit
mit auslandsbezug regeln das machen wir
natürlich ständig also steuerrecht ist
eine materie also das ist völlig
unproblematisch und aber die die
aussetzung natürlich schon durch
maßnahmen des bundesnachrichtendienstes
und so weit weniger betroffen als
bundesland hat in deutschland auch keine
hoheitsgewalt aber dass natürlich die
aus dem ausland sind und jetzt nicht
unmittelbar maßnahmen befürchten müssen
ist da eine differenzierung erforderlich
die deutet ja hier der vorsitzende auch
schon an in den vorbemerkungen also ich
denke mir da ist eine differenzierung
erforderlich sie bei gericht darauf hin
dass wohl der senat schon unterscheidet
ob ein eingriff in die kommunikation
inland ausland erfolgt oder ob eine
reine ausländische kommunikation
überwacht wird und von daher könnte ich
mir vorstellen dass in den
entscheidungsgründen schon eine aussage
getroffen wird
das sind soweit die maßstäbe geringer
anzusiedeln sind
aber eins ist klar so wie bisher global
um pauschal geht es nicht weiter bevor
wir weiter sprechen schauen wir uns mal
noch mal eine grafik an was der bnd
überhaupt macht wo einst das problem
liegt und zwar ist es ja so im digitalen
zeitalter jahr verläuft kommunikation
nicht mehr von a nach b sondern es kann
durchaus sein dass eine e mail die jetzt
von aserbaidschan nach syrien gesendet
wird erstmal über ein knotenpunkt läuft
er zum beispiel in deutschland sein kann
in frankfurt ja was macht der der bnd
der bnd satz bei diesen internetknoten
kabel an ein teil des datenstroms e
mails und telefongesprächen oder auch
chat nachrichten wird neben dem
empfänger den eben auch an den weg
geleitet aber es gibt mehrere filter
fraglich wie gut die funktionieren aber
der bnd darf nach dem gesetz eben
deutsche beziehungsweise inländische
kommunikation nicht abhören nicht
abfangen mail adressen mit de oder
telefon verbindung mit 0049 werden
herausgefiltert
naja und dann dieser riesige datenstrom
ja irgendwie auch lesbar sein und
deswegen wendet der wnt sogenannte selek
toren an
also
macht so verwendete suchbegriffe um den
datenstrom zu reduzieren können
chemische formeln in e mails seien oder
e-mail-adressen selbst oder eben mails
aus krisengebieten die in geografisch
beschränkt werden und dann wird das
ganze eben auf ein überschaubares maß
begrenzt sodass dann schließlich und
endlich ein bnd mitarbeiter vor ort
quasi die daten auswerten kann
und dann die bundesregierung soll ja der
auftrag des bundesnachrichtendienstes
über mögliche gefährdungslagen aber auch
vielleicht über andere dinge informieren
kann ja immer noch mal an sie die frage
diese diese select ohren bedeutet ja
auch das gericht an dass es da irgendwie
änderungen geben könnte wären
überwachungszwecke müssen besser
festgelegt werden auf was könnte das
jetzt hindeuten
das könnte darauf hindeuten dass im
gesetz genauer umschrieben wird zu
welchen zwecken überwachungsmaßnahmen
eingeleitet werden wie es bisher
bisher werden seitens der bundes wird
auf antrag des bnd werden bestimmte
strecken angegeben
die dann angeordnet werden seitens der
bundesregierung und dann kann der bfd
auf die entsprechenden kabel zu greifen
also es ist nicht so dass der bnd jetzt
den gesamten verkehr der etwa über de
cix in frankfurt läuft abgreifen kann
sondern es sind schon ganz konkrete
daten bündelt die auch benannt werden
und nur auf die hat der bnd dann ein
zugriff und daher kann man auch nicht
behaupten der bnd würde eine
massenüberwachung durchführen sondern
das ist schon etwas eingegrenzt von mir
sehen sie das auch so dass aktuell kann
das über wochen stattfinde kleine
massenüberwachung ist das nicht völlig
unbegrenzt ist weil sie nicht ob ich das
so stehen das würde natürlich endlich
menge von daten noch eine größere menge
könnte der bnd wahrscheinlich mit dem
personal auch gar nicht verarbeiten
aber sie haben natürlich recht dass es
eine gewisse beschränkungen gibt
trotzdem ist ja der tatbestand also das
was das gesetz zu sagen als grund für
diese überwachung angibt extrem weit im
bmw gesetzt gerade im vergleich zu dem
gesetz für inland ausland kommunikation
geht es ihm ja ein aspekt ist ja auch
immer dass man auch mit fremden diensten
zusammen arbeitet und da sagt jetzt hier
die vormerkung das ist da spezifische
voraussetzungen geben muss bei dieser
zusammenarbeit vielleicht sehen sie doch
mal wie wichtig ist denn die
zusammenarbeit mit fremden diensten für
den bundesnachrichtendienst also das hat
der präsident des bnd in der mündlichen
verhandlung deutlich zum ausdruck
gebracht dass es ohne die kooperation
mit ausländischen diensten das
nachrichtendienstliche geschäft
heutzutage nicht mehr zu bewältigen ist
und um als global player mit dabei zu
sein muss der bnd auch informationen
erfassen und auch gegebenenfalls an
dritte nachrichtendienste im ausland
übermitteln können nur so erfolgt dann
auch der datenaustausch dass der bnd von
ausländischen diensten entsprechende
wichtige informationen bekommt
allerdings hat der gesetzgeber ja auch
in das gesetz rein geschrieben dass man
darauf achten muss dass ein angemessenes
datenschutzniveau existiert insbesondere
betrifft es die übermittlung von daten
an ausländische öffentliche stellen
im gesetz ist das ganz ausdrücklich
hervorgehoben aber im rahmen der praxis
des bnd ausland ausland fernmelde
aufklärung ist meines wissens auch die
sachlage so dass man schon darauf achten
an wen kann ich welche informationen
geben
das sind jetzt mit durch eine
absichtserklärung auch jetzt hat herbert
vorgelesen dass man jetzt in zukunft vor
allem auch auf rechtsstaatliche
grundsätze in den ländern nacht geben
muss und meistens nach arbeitete bin
damit sehr
vielen geheimdiensten in vielen ländern
zusammen
rechtsstaatlichkeit ist er sicherlich
nicht überall oberste priorität ist dass
jetzt ein problem dass solche grenzen
gezogen werden sondern
bundesnachrichtendienst also ich glaube
diese grenzen sind jetzt schon in der
praxis eingehalten worden
der bnd gibt jetzt nicht pauschal
informationen an ausländische dienste
weiter wenn die gefahr besteht dass
damit missbrauch gemacht wird es gibt
natürlich situationen wo man eine
information weitergeben muss wenn man
etwa eine information erfasst dass ein
anschlag in moskau beispielsweise
geplant ist von einer bestimmten person
oder einem bestimmten gruppe
da kann man durchaus verstehen dass dann
diese information etwa an die russen
weiter gegeben werden auch wenn man
vielleicht starke bedenken hat wie die
rechtsstaatliche verfassung in russland
ist das ist ja kein problem war dass wir
im leben ist ja dass wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe der bnd auch
suchbegriffe von anderen diensten mit
unseren eigenen algorithmus quasi mit
einspeist die er vielleicht auch gar
nicht so richtig versteht und das dann
auch automatisch weiter
frau mag etwas ist da unser preislichen
aspekten von zu halten wenn also die
automatisierte weitergabe heißt ja erst
mal dass es keine überprüfungen dessen
gibt was da eigentlich für
möglicherweise problematische gruppen
betroffen sind und das wird sicherlich
so nicht stehen bleiben können wir haben
ja klar gehört also der kernbereich der
privaten lebensgestaltung muss also
dessen schutz muss sichergestellt werden
und es müssen vertraulichkeits
beziehungen geschützt werden
das sind zum beispiel genau diese
beziehungen zwischen journalistischen
quellen und die journalistin und wenn
der bnd da jetzt einfach die auf daten
automatisiert weiter gibt dann kann er
das ja gar nicht überprüfen insofern da
werden wir sicherlich neue gesetzliche
regelungen finden müssen ja zu den
vertraulichkeits beziehungen genau das
könnte bedeuten dass journalisten in
zukunft besser geschützt sind und auch
hier haben wir den ehemaligen präsident
des bundesnachrichtendienstes mal
gefragt wo er da ein problem sieht
journalismus ist wichtig aber
journalisten sind keine geschützte
berufsbezeichnung weder in deutschland
noch weltweit das bedeutet der
islamische staat könnte journalisten
ausweise verteilen und schon wären diese
terroristen als journalisten geschützt
oder die betreiber einer terroristischen
webseite in syrien oder in libyen
könnten sie stand zu recht auf artikel
10 berufen
das gericht hat gesagt auch die
pressefreiheit ist verletzt durch die
regelung wie soll man hier ab schichten
wann ist man so etwas sagen gegen sie
dem handy hat in diesem verfahren
versucht viele nebelkerzen zu werfen und
das ist glaube ich eine davon dass der
begriff journalist keine geschützte
bezeichnung ist ja gerade dass wenn
jemand ein presseausweis hat das noch
nicht heißt dass man ihn unbedingt als
journalisten behandeln muss also
insofern würde ich doch hoffen dass
unser bundesnachrichtendienst in der
lage ist festzustellen ob jemand
wirklich journalismus oder nicht denn
einfach glauben muss er ist nämlich
gerade nicht das ist gerade sozusagen
der clou dessen dass es keine geschützte
berufsbezeichnung ist ja also vieles ist
da noch unklar wir müssen also die
urteilsgründe letztlich abwarten aber es
gibt schon einige erkenntnisse die ich
dann noch mal zusammenfassen
und zwar erstens grundrechte gelten auch
für ausländer im ausland der bnd darf
diese aktuelle pauschale globale
überwachung so nicht mehr fortführen
der grundsatz der verhältnismäßigkeit
ist nämlich dadurch verletzt und der bd
wird aber die möglichkeit beibehalten
dürfen durch den daten auszuwerten
in zukunft wird er aber wohl besser
begründen müssen warum das hier dann
jeweils die sicherheit der
bundesrepublik deutschland gefährden
kann und damit vielen dank und wir geben
zurück nach bonn
das bundesverfassungsgericht kippt die
regelung zur bnd abhörpraxis wermes eben
gehört die überwachung der
telekommunikation von ausländern im
ausland nach dem bnd gesetz verstoße in
seiner jetzigen form gegen das
telekommunikationsgeheimnis und die
pressefreiheit so hat das höchste
gericht das höchste deutsche gericht
heute in karlsruhe eben gerade
entschieden
wir kehren zurück